have to start off by saying
condragulations
good on you might Emmy nominee yeah now
I know you've said you'd rather get an
enema than an Emmy
yeah and I've had several action this
morning we're gonna make drag race
history logo whose you know it's been
this fledgling Network for many years
and now this kind of recognition from
the television industries is a big deal
why do you think it took so long the
show has been killer every single season
no that's sweet of you but why wasn't
this season that got the golden boy yeah
I don't know you know when I went to
junior high school you know we all voted
for our friends and if you have enough
friends
that's how you get votes I mean a lot of
times in this industry you know you have
to make a lot of friends you can get
them to vote for you
so I'm counting on ya do you think
you're gonna win I don't know I don't
really I don't really I feel like I've
won every year the show is be picked up
by logo because really nothing beats a
paycheck
I love it you said you'll come back as
long as they're handing out the check
honey here that's what this it's called
show business I'm not doing this you
know because I you know have a well
actually I was gonna say enough for fun
but actually is a lot of fun doing the
show we have so much fun and we get to
launch the careers of all these young
kids who have a dream is really the
biggest payoff of all what can we expect
from Rouen I mean I cuz you're gonna be
there yes we just have to wait and see
yeah you have to wait and watch and see
you know again like I said you know we
don't stand on ceremony
so whatever whim that strikes my fancy
that's that's what we'll do but you know
I like to like to focus on today and
that's the way I live my life but you
know tomorrow really doesn't exist I
don't want to get to California will
rule on you but I'll just stay in the
moment